this is how Albert is I mean he's like a
little doll Albert is three years old he
was of the runt of the litter and he was
really tiny Albert was one cat from
health for a licking problem and we were
also on Animal Planet for this show
called America's Next cat star and they
put a bunch of cats that you know are
predicted to become famous
I started his Instagram account when I
went to a cat festival people were just
you know winged and ahhing over him
Albert has not always been famous he's
been made famous by heavy marketing
Albert's most notable posts would be his
moonwalking where I put Albert on the
window ledge and I you know started
filming him I was like Albert come here
but his butt was facing me and then all
of a sudden he started walking backwards
and I put it up on Instagram and
instantly the comments just flooded in
it was like everybody was tagging all
their friends
all those costumes are really hard to
find because you can't really find that
many good pet costumes the ones in pet
stores are usually low quality so I had
to get creative usually shop at Babies R
Us or try to find human infant clothes
so the way we usually do shoots is he
gets distracted a lot we put him in a
costume we'll have to have some toys
like he knows that he's being
photographed so he'll do everything in
his power to look away from the camera
did we do a lot of sponsored posts the
biggest ones we've done are for
coca-cola Walgreens yeah we did one for
the Deadpool movie when we first started
it was very difficult for us to get
sponsored post you were only being
approached by pet companies I work
really hard on Albert's account with his
photos and I do this full-time so I
thought why not why can't we get some
sponsors at first we got a lot of people
that didn't understand the sponsored
content especially because he's a cat
advertising products that are not
related to pets but what people don't
understand is that we love doing albert
posts and videos and photos but just
because we love it doesn't mean that we
shouldn't get paid for it if people
really love Alber like they should be
understanding about that we're putting
so much work into this we can't afford
to do it for free all the time I work so
hard on getting more followers every day
it's a day-to-day thing every single day
is me thinking about okay what's the
next step
my goal in life is always to do what I
love that's what I've been doing with
Albert you know I love him so much and
it's so much fun spending time with them
I'm taking videos and photos of him I've
turned my hobby into a career